l'hebdo politique bonsoir et bienvenue
dans l'hebdo politique votre rendez vous
du dimanche soir sur radio sensations en
association avec tv 78 épisodes 201 ce
soir mon invité et othman nasri ouf
[Musique]
les politiques
maintenant d'un scoop bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes candidat trappe engagements
citoyens pour les élections municipales
du 10 octobre 2021 alors on va rappeler
tout d'abord votre parcours en 2012 vous
commencez votre investissement politique
attrapant fond dans le collectif trappe
citoyens qui conduisaient des actions
locales sur le thème du logement entre
autres en 2014 vous conduisait une liste
d'union ump udi modem et vous pardonner
vous parvenez pardon à atteindre le
second tour avec 32 53 % des voix
derrière le maire sortant socialiste de
l'époque guy malandain vous est alors
élu conseiller municipal d'opposition ce
qui vous permet d'être élu également à
l'agglomération chef de file de
l'opposition ensuite à trappes vous est
alors repéré par valérie pécresse pour
les élections régionales de 2015 vous
devenez son porte parole dans les
yvelines puis après la victoire vous
devenez conseiller régional d'abord vice
président au développement économique
puis ensuite vice président aux affaires
internationales et au tourisme en 2007
vous prenez la présidence du groupe au
compte de la majorité au conseil
régional et en 2020 enfin vous êtes de
nouveau présent aux élections
municipales à trappes alors cette fois
vous terminer devant le maire sortant
guy malandain mais derrière ali rabais
son ancien adjoint si vous êtes de
nouveau candidat cette année c'est parce
que le conseil d'état a invalidé
l'élection à la suite d'un recours que
vous avez déposé il a été reproché à
lies rabais d'avoir distribué des
masques des colis alimentaires ou encore
des kits pédagogiques sans les avoir
déclaré ensuite dans ses comptes de
campagne l'écart entre vous et monsieur
rabais n'étende alors que 260 et une
voix le conseil d'état a jugé que cela
avait pu altérer la sincérité du scrutin
voilà donc pourquoi les trappistes
doivent voter à nouveau pour élire leur
maire
d'octobre prochain une nouvelle élection
donc avec d'autres candidats robert naga
retina mais luc miserait mais aussi des
changements importants sur la ligne de
départ l'ancien maire socialiste guy
malandain vous a rejoint pour former une
liste d'union mais c'est une liste
d'union pour trappe ou c'est une liste
d'union surtout contre monsieur rabais
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose que
l'intérêt de la ville aujourd'hui c'est
que on met ensemble toutes les
compétences qu'on met de côté les
clivages partisans les débats de
politique nationale c'est pas ça la
gestion d'une ville c'est pas des
étiquettes c'est de l'apaisement c'est
de la sérénité c'est de la compétence et
de porter le dossier important c'est
d'être en capacité de les financer en
ayant pour cela la confiance des
partenaires agglomération département
région état et tout cela nous l'avons
nous l'avons avec di malanda également
avec mustapha larfaoui on avait déjà
commencé à dépasser tous les clivages
stérile en 2020 et aujourd'hui nous
allons plus loin mais c'est vrai qu'on a
depuis un an une gestion municipale avec
monsieur rabais qui est extrêmement
préoccupante la campagne de 2020 on
avait donné une idée puisque l'élection
à été annulée pour un poids non respect
des règles de financement électoral et
aujourd'hui après un temps on peut tirer
un premier bilan on a une mairie qui ne
fonctionne plus une propriété de la
ville qui s'est dégradée des méthodes
particulièrement brutale d'un
clientélisme débridée qui est en train
aujourd'hui de freiner le développement
de la ville et donc ça nécessite que
tout les tous les républicains sincères
se mettre ensemble et bien pour proposer
un autre chemin pour l'avenir de trappes
pendant des années dit malandain et est
votre principal opposant les relations
étaient parfois tumultueuses entre vous
deux qu'est ce qui fait que maintenant
vous êtes prêts à travailler ensemble et
à dépasser ces clivages en 2014 j'ai
porté effectivement un projet qui
consistait à donner à notre avenir à
trappes mary guy malandain nous avons
toujours eu du respect il n'y avait pas
les invectives qu'on observe aujourd'hui
avec monsieur rabais il n'y avait pas d'
insulte n'y avait pas de grossir t il
n'y avait pas 20 procédures en justice
lancée par celui qui restait mer pendant
une année avant d'être démis de ses
fonctions et donc ont appris à se
connaître avec guy malandain - j'ai mûri
je me suis préparée je pense aujourd'hui
être prêt à assumer la fonction de maire
est lui aussi considère aujourd'hui que
je suis le mieux placé pour faire équipe
et pour qu'ensemble nous portions un
nouvel avenir pour trappe et je veux le
dire encore une fois je les dis dès 2020
ans j'ai de l'estimé pour guy malandain
sa hauteur de vue son expérience vont
nous être utile et en même temps je
continue de porter un projet de
changement pour trappe et face à ali
rabé il fallait encore une fois que tous
les républicains sincères s'unissent
parce qu'on ne peut pas laisser notre
ville sont foncés dans le clientélisme
qu'elle connaît depuis l'élection de
2020 dit malandain il a affirmé qu'il y
avait en fait trois têtes de listes dans
votre liste vous lui ai aussi mustapha
larbaoui ce que vous confirmez cette
description les choses sont simples
quand on fait l'union ont fait la place
à des gens qui ont aussi des
sensibilités politiques différentes tant
qu'on est d'accord sur l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire un projet pour trappe et
qu'on mette de côté tout ce qui de
l'ordre de la politisation extrême et
monsieur rabehi la fée linverse il a
tout politiser jusqu aux agents
municipaux je vous rappelle qu'il n'y a
plus de 30 responsables municipaux qui
ont quitté la mairie à cause d'un climat
de pression et d'intimidation
moi je suis heureux de pouvoir
travailler avec un responsable
associatif comme moustapha larbaoui qui
a présidé les clubs de foot pendant 14
ans qui est un professionnel de santé
avec guy malandain quand une fois qui
connaît particulièrement bien beaucoup
de dossiers importants pour la ville et
nous allons mettre et avec eux
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres citoyens de
trappes que ce bon certains sont bien
connus qui sont les acteurs de la ville
qui sont représentatifs de la diversité
de trappes et on met de côté les
questions de politique nationale mais on
travaille ensemble pour tirer la ville
vers le haut alors justement une liste
c'est aussi enfin il y a de la tête de
liste mais aussi la liste en elle-même
qui fait partie de cette liste est ce
que tous les bords politiques sont
représentés moi quand les gens veulent
travailler pour trappe je ne leur
demande pas ce qu'ils votent nationale
je ne leur demande pas ce qu'ils votent
pour les présidentielles salé par mon
sujet ma sensibilité politique et les
connue elle est assumée j'en suis fier
je porte les valeurs qui sont les
miennes mais la gestion quotidienne
d'une ville ça n'est pas ça ce n'est pas
un parti qui gagne contre les autres et
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui pour proposer un
autre chemin que celui et délires ab où
il met toute la ville au service d'un
parti unique d'un clan même j'ai envie
de dire c'est ce qu'on observe dans sa
gestion aujourd'hui donc nous nous
faisons l'inversé donc bien sûr il ya
des responsables associatifs des gens
qui sont issus du monde de l'entreprise
des gens qui travaillent aussi au
quotidien des commerçants donc tout cela
est bien va donner une équipe surtout
compétente et qui a un seul objectif
l'efficacité et la recherche de
résultats concrets pour faire avancer
trappe non lors de la précédente
élection en 2020 l'abstention était
extrêmement forte
61,75 % d'abstention au second tour
comment est ce que vous expliquez cette
abstention des trappistes et est-ce que
selon vous ça va être la clé pour cette
élection 2021 on les attrape la seule
ville de saint quentin en yvelines où
les élections sont annulés dire bien au
delà de saint-quentin-en-yvelines cela
faisait 40 ans que ça n'était pas arrivé
et ça n'est pas anodin et c'est vrai que
ça contribue à donner une image de la
politique qui regrettable on ne devrait
pas être prêt à tout pour gagner une
élection et surtout les règles
s'appliquent à tout le monde et en
particulier aux élus et donc nous notre
défi avec mostafa larbaoui avec guy
malandain et avec toute l'équipe qui
nous qui nous rejoint une quarantaine de
colistiers et puis les milliers
trappistes qui nous soutiennent depuis
2020 et encore plus aujourd'hui et bien
c'est de redonner envie en disant voilà
ce que nous allons changer dans la
gestion municipale et voilà ce qui va
changer concrètement pour les habitants
on a un projet on a la capacité de le
mettre en oeuvre et j'espère que c'est
cela qui va faire que la participation
va être au rendez vous pour donner à
trappes encore une fois un autre avenir
que ce que nous connaissons depuis un an
on va essayer avec menace codalet plus
concrètement dans les sujets qui
touchent la mairie de trappes nous
allons voir plusieurs thèmes de campagne
avec vous dans cette émission est tout
d'abord l'éducation depuis l'année
dernière les écoles de trappes sont
repassés au système de quatre jours à
l'école est ce que vous toucherez plus
assurée je suis celui qui a défendu le
retour aux quatre jours depuis 2014 j'ai
même été aux côtés des parents d'élèves
quand ils le réclamaient et donc
naturellement nous allons garder les
quatre jours nous allons garder leur
d'études dont monsieur rabé avait voté
la suppression en 2015 qui l'a rétablie
aujourd'hui mais je veux dire que c'est
une heure d'étude ce n'est pas une heure
de garderie est aujourd'hui les retours
de terrain qu'on a c'est que il ne faut
pas faire que de l'affichage ces
changements là ils doivent avoir un vrai
contenu pédagogique lors d'études c'est
une heure de soutien scolaire une aide
aux devoirs il faut qu'on améliore la
qualité de l'accompagnement la qualité
de l'encadrement et c'est ça qui est
aujourd'hui attendu donc nous allons
garder ces changements mais nous allons
surtout les mettre réellement en oeuvre
au delà de ce qui a été fait un peu à la
va vite pour cette année là c'est un
début mais je reconnais beaucoup plus
loin par exemple je veux qu'il y ait
désormais un ou une atsem par classe
c'est à dire un accompagnement
périscolaire l accompagnement de la
municipalité avec l'éducation nationale
beaucoup plus fort en termes de moyens
humains on en a la capacité financière
aujourd'hui vous savez le jour de la
rentrée il manquait dix personnes dans
les effectifs qui n'étaient pas à leur
poste donc cette désorganisation là elle
n'est pas possible il faut qu'on
correcteurs promettent de la qualité
maintenant et pas seulement de
l'affichage ou de la communication dans
les mesures qui sont mises en oeuvre
mais nous gardons les quatre jours nous
gardant leur d'études nous gardons
l'organisation de la cantine qui a été
adopté mais là aussi il faut de la
qualité dans les assiettes parce que
apprendre à bien manger c'est un
apprentissage dès le plus jeune âge et
c'est fondamental pour le reste de la
vie sur la question du pouvoir d'achat
des familles ali rabais propose que la
mairie offre les titres de fournitures
scolaires aux élèves en élémentaire et
propose également la création d'une
centrale d'achat pour les collégiens les
lycéens afin de réduire le coût de la
rentrée qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
propositions à lire ab a bien lu notre
projet 2020 puisque tous ces éléments là
il figure noir sur blanc et il ne
figurait pas dans le sien tout comme les
quatre jours n'ont jamais été son combat
mais c'est bien qu'il s'inspire de ce
qui marche et ce qui marche ailleurs par
contre il propose aussi d'offrir un vélo
à tous à tous les enfants de la ville ça
c'est une proposition totalement
démagogique n'ont pas d'intérêt éducatif
en tant que tel et en vêtements il faut
pas faire campagne en essayant de
d'acheter les électeurs ce qui a été
fait en 2020 c'est ce qui a été retoqué
par la justice il faut le faire sur le
fond et donc faut pas multiplier les
cadeaux qu'on aide évidemment à ce qu'on
ait un matériel adapté pour toutes les
familles je peux le comprendre la
centrale d'achat et notamment une
proposition pour mutualiser et faire
baisser les prix qui existait dans notre
projet mais le sujet aujourd'hui qui
manquera trappe c'est notamment le
matériel numérique sur lequel nous avons
pris un certain retard par rapport à
d'autres communes ce retard commence à
peine à être rattrapé au début du mandat
une commande avait été annulée par la
municipalité nous l'avions dénoncé
aujourd'hui ça revient je précise que
ses finances et ses matériels numériques
dans les écoles est financé par
l'agglomération et par lé département
hauteur de 70% donc ça ne coûte pas
beaucoup à la ville il faut qu'on aille
plus loin comme par exemple et l'encours
a pu le faire il ya maintenant de
nombreuses années pour couronner un
accompagnement le plus qualitatif
possible autre sujet important
maintenant ce sont les travaux dans
fluide d'enfouissement de la n10 le
chantier a déjà débuté l'objectif et
d'enfouir la route nationale qui coupe
la ville en deux un plateau urbain sera
créé les travaux devraient durer
jusqu'en 2028 donc ce sera un peu le fil
rouge du prochain mandat le projet avait
été initié d'ailleurs par l'ancien maire
guy malandain l'opération coûtera 100
millions d'euros est financé en partie
par l'état et toutes les collectivités
territoriales qui y participent la ville
de trappes elle mettra 2 millions
d'euros dans ce projet selon le parisien
auquel il faudra ajouter le coût de
l'aménagement ensuite du plateau urbain
c'est un projet d'une grande importance
pour trappe bien sûr c'est un projet
fondateur dont on a parlé depuis
longtemps moi je c'est un projet que
j'ai suivi de très près avec la région
on est le second financeur après l'état
et j'ai toujours attentif à ce qu'on
voit comment on peut fait réaménager ce
projet pour qu'il apporte le maximum de
bien-être aux habitants et c'est pour
cela que d'avoir l'expérience de di
malanda ces précieux c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît parfaitement bien notamment ce
sujet et donc il va apporter son
expérience parce qu'aujourd'hui des
travaux sont prévus pour durer plus de
six années presque sept ans c'est long
les délais ont été d'ailleurs très
largement étendue il faut qu'on regarde
pourquoi depuis un angle c'est plus rien
passer sur ce dossier il n'y a pas eu
une réunion avec les habitants par
exemple pour leur dire où on en est
pourquoi les délais dérape comment
est-ce qu'on va améliorer la question du
bruit et la question de la pollution de
l'air qui ne sont pas suffisamment
prises en compte aujourd'hui c'est un
bon projet parce qu'il à recoudre la
ville mais il faut penser à comment on
profite pour faire tout le reste parce
que c'est pas tous les jours qu'on aura
100 millions d'euros qui vont être
investis par les partenaires de la ville
qui vous savez ils sont et non pour
faire avec qui je travaille beaucoup
c'est 100 millions d'euros pour trappe
et reste la question du plateau urbains
là aussi pas une seule réunion de
concertation avec les habitants en un an
il faut qu'on revienne vers les
habitants pour savoir que fait-on est-ce
qu'on fait du logement sur ce plateau
urbain moi je ne le souhaite pas je
pense qu'il faut arrêter la
densification qu'il faut faire
maintenant des lieux de vie travail et
le cadre de vie des espaces verts des
lieux de vie des lieux de loisirs des
commerces c'est un défi fondamental
attrape la diversité des commerces
aujourd'hui et notre défi majeur et
c'est un sujet sur lequel je suis
déterminé à agir très rapidement mais
donc ce sujet de lundi s'il est bien
entamée aujourd'hui il faut qu'on le
mène jusqu'au bout micro le maine
sérieusement avec des gens compétents
qui ont envie d'avoir des résultats
concrets au bénéfice des habitants alors
ce grand chantier dndi s'il entraînera
fortement des nuisances pour les
riverains qui habitent à proximité
pendant six ans et quand une période
très longue comment faire pour les
réduire au maximum ses nuisances c'est
exactement ce que je vous disais
il ya par exemple aujourd'hui
l'isolation phonique qui n'est pas
suffisamment au rendez vous moi j'ai
proposé qu' il puisse y avoir un
revêtement antibruit sur la route ce qui
s'est fait ailleurs la veille gens là
par exemple financer dans le tunnel à
l'haÿ-les-roses et on a remarqué que le
bruit était divisée par quatre dents
avec ce type de revêtement qui qui sont
contre le bruit tout simplement qu'ils
absorbent le bruit est donc je souhaite
que ce type d'aménagement puisse se
faire dans le projet actuel
malheureusement le temps presse et je
les dis le dialogue entre la ville et
des partenaires aujourd'hui n'existe
quasiment plus la ville est isolée et
donc on ne peut plus porter ce type de
messages et donc nous souhaitons nous
reprend un dialogue serein avec les
partenaires pour voir ce que nous
pouvons faire et y compris dans le
phasage des travaux guy malandain par
exemple avait défendu un scénario dans
lequel les travaux été bouclé en quatre
ans on est aujourd'hui à six années et
demie depuis depuis depuis cette année
donc il faut qu'on réexamine tout cela
attentivement dans le dialogue et
surtout dans la transparence vis-à-vis
des trappistes alors sur l'aménagement
du plateau urbain vous avez donné votre
position pup a pas de logements en tout
cas sur l'écologie justement on en vient
à ce thème à votre échelle de mer comme
moi ce que vous vous lui auriez contre
le réchauffement climatique la ville
doit être exemplaire en matière de
transition énergétique et
malheureusement ce virage n'a pas encore
été suffisamment pris malgré les slogans
de campagne et le fait que les
programmes soient en verre que les
bulletins de vote sont ouverts dans la
réalité la politique municipale qui
menait depuis un an n'est pas verte il
n'y a pas eu d'achats de rats flotte de
deux de la mairie de conversion à
l'électrique il n'y a pas eu de
dispositifs par exemple sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments qui
peut être proposé aux habitants bien sûr
et tout cela figurait déjà dans notre
produit en 2020 et nous avons la
capacité de le financer moi je suis vice
président d'une région qui a pour la
dans le bus dont le budget pardon est à
moitié 1 euros sur 2 à destination de la
transition écologique aujourd'hui à un
impact positif sur l'environnement
j'aimerais que notre ville en profite de
ses ressources à y chercher ces dossiers
là pas un dossier n'a été déposé à la
région sur ce sujet de la transition
énergétique depuis un an c'est dommage
parce que ce sont des ressources en moi
pour les habitants mais la première
écologie la première
nécessité environnementale c'est d'avoir
la propreté de la ville nous avons
besoin d'une ville qui soit propre qu'il
soit bien entretenu ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui il ya un laisser-aller qui
n'est pas acceptable et le cadre de vie
l'écologie le soin envers la nature
c'est d'abord la propreté c'est d'abord
que les déchets soient bien ramassé
c'est que la ville soit propre et là
dessus nous mettrons des moyens massifs
donc c'est ça passe par le financement
d'autres d'autres moyens trappes a été
très médiatisée l'année dernière dans
les médias la ville a été le théâtre de
nombreuses polémiques certains l'a
désigné même comme un territoires perdus
de la république vous souhaitez je vous
cite améliorer l'image de trappes grâce
à une stratégie de communication
exemplaires que ferez vous pour redorer
l'image de la ville
d'abord il faut que nous ayons je les
dis une gestion apaisée rassembleuse que
nous serions pas dans la division dans
les polémiques dans les effets de manche
dans l'agressivité face à la caméra ça
n'est jamais bon et ces images qu'on a
vu à l'occasion d'une polémique
regrettable parce que beaucoup de
trappes ils se sont sentis à juste titre
pointée du doigt et moi je le redis je
veux dire très clairement trap est une
ville que que j'aime j'ai consacré
maintenant eu plus de huit années
d'engagement
et je veux le meilleur pour trappe et
pour ça je pense que il faut qu'on donne
une autre image de la ville une image
apaisée qu'on montre aussi nos succès
nos réussites et puis aussi
effectivement les défis qu'il faut que
l'on sache relevé par exemple sur la
question de la sécurité qui est une
demande aujourd'hui des trappistes quand
on aura une police municipale 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 quand on aura un
travail vraiment d'éducation vers la
jeunesse pour laquelle il ya des
dispositifs qui existent mais qu'on
laisse aujourd'hui sans activité en bas
des immeubles sans activité de loisir et
sans activité professionnelle sans
formation et sans emploi alors qu'il y à
des dispositifs qui existent et que la
ville ne va pas chercher on ne contribue
pas à donner une bonne image de la ville
il faut tirer la ville vers le haut et
une fois que nous aurons commencé ce
travail il faut aller vendre tout ce
travail là dans les médias moi je
commence à avoir l'habitude des ddd des
plateaux télé de télévision il faut
profiter ce sont des vitrines pour
donner une autre image de la ville mais
encore une fois dans le respect et dans
l'apaisement dans la sérénité avant tout
vous avez parlé de la police municipale
ce que vous allez engager une réforme de
cette police ça fait des années que je
le propose
et malheureusement depuis un an là les
effectifs de la police municipale ont
été divisés par deux il n'y a
aujourd'hui plus que quatre policiers
municipaux en activité à trappes c'est
impensable c'est impensable moi je
défends depuis le départ une police
municipale qui doit au contraire triplé
alors qu'elle a été divisée par deux
donc là on a encore plus de chemin à
faire simplement pour qu'elle puisse
fonctionner 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 et puis il faut que ces missions soir
redéfini le rôle de la police municipale
telle que je la conçois si je suis maire
c'est de lutter contre les nuisances des
incivilités les occupations de halls
d'immeuble le cadre de vie c'est de se
déplacer quand les habitants la réclame
est d'être vraiment présente dans le
respect dans le dialogue mais aussi pour
apporter tout ce que la police nationale
ne peut plus faire c'est-à-dire une
véritable police de proximité c'est son
rôle et là dessus on l'a perdu
malheureusement un an de travail donc
c'est un engagement très clair qui ne
coûtera rien trappistes la région ile de
france verse 30 millions d'euros de
subventions tous les ans à plus de 300
communes qui font la demande en matière
de sécurité notamment d'équipement des
polices municipales la ville de travail
n'en a pas fait la moindre demande donc
vous entretenez de très bonnes relations
de ces avec jean michel fourgous le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
mais aussi avec valérie pécresse la
présidente de la région ile de france
est ce que ces relations pourront selon
vous vous aider à améliorer l'image de
la ville de trappes l'agglomération la
région mais également le département ce
sont les partenaires naturels ce sont
les principaux financeurs de la ville il
faut qu'on puisse travailler de manière
fluide et ça n'est pas une question de
bord politique ce n'est pas simplement
une question de bord politique c'est une
question de respect des partenaires
c'est une question de dialogue d'écouté
de ne pas être dans l'agressivité dans
la brutalité et j'ai le sentiment que la
ville elle s'est isolée elle s'est
coupée de ses partenaires là je voulais
dit mais d'autres partenaires l' agence
nationale pour la rénovation urbaine
avec laquelle le dialogue est coupé
aujourd'hui alors que nous attendons
encore la rénovation de camus un dossier
sur lequel il ne se passe plus rien
depuis un an c'est un dossier
fondamental pour les années à venir et
donc oui j'ai la chance de bien
connaître ces différents acteurs dans le
rôle institutionnel ça va nous permettre
d'aller plus vite sur un certain nombre
de dossiers de bénéficier de moyens
importants pour financer nos projets
mais encore une fois ce n'est pas une
question de proximité politique c'est
une question de manière de faire de
manière d'être peut-être parce que
l'équipe que nous construisons quitte
une équipe de rassemblement d'union
républicaine je pense qu'elle est de
nature à inspirer la confiance des
partenaires et à nous permettre de
travailler de manière efficace dans le
seul intérêt de trappes et des
trappistes alors pour l'image de la
ville pour être fiers de trappes ça
passe aussi par les associations de la
ville vous en êtes à un membre actif des
associations qu'est ce que vous ferez
pour la vie associative à trappes pour
l'améliorer d'abord nous allons arrêter
le clientélisme je suis désolé de le
dire sous cette forme là mais quand on
divise par deux les subventions aux
associations par exemple de personnes
âgées
parce que les dirigeants de cette
association ont fait un autre choix
politique au moment des élections
municipales de 2020 c'est inacceptable
c'est inacceptable et donc vous voyez
que ça n'est pas une question de droite
ou de gauche la solidarité la vraie
solidarité elle est dans les actes elle
n'est pas simplement dans les paroles
dans les slogans de campagne et ça nous
voulons arrêter ce type de règlement de
compte politique ça n'a aucun intérêt et
l'équipe l'alliance l'union que nous
construisons elle prouve qu'il n'y aura
pas un grand politique contre l'autre
puisque vous avez des gens de
sensibilité différente dans cette équipe
et donc il faut que ce soit l'efficacité
au service des trappistes qui
conditionne les subventions aux
associations mais leur écrasante
majorité fait un travail remarquable
nous sacralise rond évidemment tous les
budgets je pense notamment aux
associations sportives qui qui mérite
d'être soutenue qui joue un rôle
éducatif majeur est donc évidemment que
nous serons là aussi au rendez-vous des
engagements de la ville mais là aussi il
ya des moyens que la vie ne va pas
chercher et notamment auprès des
partenaires il y à des subventions est
compris dans le sport nous avons par
exemple verser une subvention au club de
foot de la ville par la région ile de
france la mairie pourrait être un moyen
d'aller chercher ces subventions là
parce que malheureusement beaucoup
d'acteurs de terrain ne sont pas au
courant de tous les dispositifs qui
existent on apparaître à l'heure de
monsieur guy malandain mais monsieur
mustapha larfaoui et l ancien président
du club de foot pendant 14 ans est-ce
que cela va permettre d'avoir des
meilleures relations avec les
associations oui messieurs larbaoui
quelqu'un qui connaît extrêmement bien
le monde associatif qui a dirigé pendant
14 ans de club de foot qui n'est pas une
tâche facile et il a eu un travail
pédagogique absolument exemplaire à la
tête de ce club de foot et tout le monde
le lui reconnaît et il sera un acteur
majeur de ce travail éducatif que nous
voulons faire de ce dialogue avec les
associations
pas simplement sportive mais également
culturel il a aussi une association qui
s'appelle pharma citoyen qui a fait
beaucoup de choses en matière de soutien
scolaire en matière aussi de solidarité
envers les personnes âgées en matière de
lien social cette solidarité là qui est
très vive à trappes qui vit vraiment qui
est vivante il faut pas la casser à
cause de calculs politiciens il faut au
contraire continuer à dynamiser sa
travail de tous les instants et par
exemple je regrette que les comités de
quartier qui fonctionnait jusque là qui
mérite d'être amplifié et bien
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne plus depuis un
an il faut au contraire pour les
autonomistes davantage et qu'on les
relances très rapidement dès notre
élection pour concussion avoir les
remontées de terrain de tous les
aménagements et de toute la vie de
quartier qu'il faut soigner et sur
laquelle il faut travailler plus
sérieusement pour essai sur les
associations sportives parce que vous
allez investir notamment dans les
infrastructures sportives
oui il est prévu là dessus les choses
sont très simples nous avons aujourd'hui
moins d'infrastructures sportives que
d'autres villes que la moyenne régionale
pour être précis en termes de taux
d'équipements sportifs et puis surtout
un certain nombre sont relativement
vétuste je pense au gymnase gagarine je
pense au gymnase rousseau qui est
vraiment très vétuste et ce sont des
absolument des projets d'investissement
qu'il faut porter dès le début du mandat
qu'il faut inscrire dans le budget qui
mettront bien sûr plusieurs années à se
faire mais qui aujourd'hui ne sont même
pas prévu et là-dessus aussi les
financements existent je pense par
exemple à l'extension de la piscine
jacques mango qui est un vieux sujet un
vieux serpent de mer nous région on a
financé le projet de piscine à elancourt
maurepas la piscine intercommunale
d'elancourt maurepas pour huit cent
mille euros j'ai regretté que la ville a
aussi depuis un an ne dépose pas de
dossier des financements il y en a ce
qui manque aujourd'hui c'est le travail
sérieux concret sur les dossiers avec
tous ceux qui veulent pousser la ville
dans le bon sens et donc oui il faudra
qu'on aurait nouvion un certain nombre
d'équipements sportifs et que nous en
attendions un certain nombre ça se fera
tout au long du prochain mandat alors
passons dernier sujet avant votre carte
blanche sur la problématique du logement
maintenant vous êtes engagé vous depuis
notamment longtemps grâce à votre
association vous constatez qu'il ya trop
d'abus qui touche les locataires
aujourd'hui ça a été mon combat je pense
même pouvoir dire que je suis le seul
élu de la ville qui s'est saisie de ce
sujet parce qu'il y ait un comportement
parfois d'un certain nombre de bailleurs
sociaux qui ne sont pas acceptables on
ne peut pas laisser des familles sans
réponse pendant des mois alors qu'ils
n'ont plus de chauffage on peut pas
laisser des moisissures or et de
l'insalubrité dans des logements et
considérer que c'est normal on ne peut
pas laisser des charges à des niveaux
très élevés alors que le contrôle des
charges qui fait par les associations de
locataires et vraiment je veux les en
féliciter révèle que ce sont des charges
qui ne sont qui sont indus qui doivent
être remboursés aux locataires nous
avons eu cette année notamment beaucoup
de charges qui étaient injustifiées et
une partie a été reversée aux locataires
à la demande des associations de
représentants de locataires je regrette
que la mairie n'aide pas ce travail le
rôle d'un maire c'est de dire aux
bailleurs que la partie est finie que
les règles sont faites pour être
respectées et qu'un bailleur a aussi des
obligations en matière d'entretien en
matière de maîtrise des charges ça
suppose de les mettre en demeure quand
ce n'est pas le cas ça suppose d'aider
les associations à faire le contrôle des
charges c'est un engagement qui m'est
très cher parce que je voulais vu de mes
yeux - comme l'eau courante a été coupée
à au square thorez pendant quatre jours
d'affilée en 2013 j'étais là et j'ai
compris qu'elle avait un problème de
dialogue avec notamment un bailleur de
la ville je souhaite que dès notre
élection on explique que la partie est
finie et maintenant que les règles
s'appliquent à trappes comme dans
n'importe quelle autre ville on arrive à
la fin de cette émission une dernier un
dernier mot pour les trappistes qui vous
regarde oui il ya un sujet qui me tient
à coeur qui était aussi beaucoup paquet
mustapha larfaoui mais également un guy
malandain c'est la question de l'emploi
des jeunes
moi je ne peux pas accepter qu'il y ait
des dispositifs qui existent il qu'on
fasse pas le maximum pour tirer notre
jeunesse vers le haut aujourd'hui à la
région nous ont le permis de conduire
gratuit pour les jeunes qui cherchent un
emploi nous faisons des formation
professionnelle qualifiante
avec 70% de chances de trouver un métier
au bout qui sont gratuites voire parfois
rémunérés je ne comprends pas que la
mairie ne ne va pas aider notre jeunesse
à aller vers ces dispositifs là qui sont
une chance aujourd'hui pour la ville et
donc mon combat ça va être encore une
fois 4 ap nous ayons dans les années à
venir aucun jeune qui soit sans emploi
et sans formation c'est un engagement
très clair que je veux prendre parce que
tirer notre jeunesse vers le haut lui
donner les vraies opportunités d'avenir
c'est ce qui va aussi faire que notre
vie tu vas réussir merci de manas woods
est revenu dans l'hebdo politi je
rappelle que vous êtes candidat à la
mairie de trappes le premier tour aura
lieu le 10 octobre prochain dé nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de l'hebdo politique très
bonne soirée à tous
les politiques
[Musique]